[MUSIC]
We are now ready to learn about
the key algorithmic technique called
dynamic programming, and
to learn about the dynamic programming we
will look at the very simple change
property.
You walk to the supermarket, you pay
for Compeau and Pevzner book,
and you have 40 cents in change.
And now cashier is making a decision,
how to give you this change?
The cashier can give you a quarter, a
dime,
an extra 5 cents, I think it will be three
coins.
But cashier also has a choice of giving
you 40 pence.
The change problem is to find the minimum
number
of coins to change a given amount of
money.
And the first thing that come to mind is
actually the approach that cashiers
all over the world use.
They simply look at the amount of money
they
have to change, and they find the maximum
denomination,
maximum coin that
doesn't exceed the money.
They give you this coin, subtract this
coin from the amount of money, and
iterate.
Do we think this approach would produce an
optimal solution?
In fact, it will produce an optimal
solution
in United States, but not in Tanzania.
Tanzania has beautiful coin,
shown here, and they actually, in addition to
quarters, they have a 20 cents coin.
So, while great algorithm, in Tanzania,
will result in three coins as a change,
because it starts from 25 as largest coin, smaller
than 40, then it's ten, then it's five.
The right thing to change money in
Tanzania is simply to give you
two 20 cents coin.
So what algorithm should we design to
change money in Tanzania optimally?
Let's design a recursive change algorithm.
And let's imagine that we are in a strange
country where
there are only three coins: 6, 5 and 1 cents.
How would we change
9 cents using these coins.
Well to change 9 cents, to find optimal
amount of money (coins)
optimal means number of coins to change
9 cents, we can find
minimum number of coins to change 8 cents
and to add 1 penny.
Or minimum number of coins to change 4 cents
and to add 5 cents coin
one more coin, or to find the minimum
number of coins to change
3 cents and add more coin, right.
And therefore the minimum number of coins for
9 cents is the minimum of the minimum number of
coins for
8, 4 or 3 cents plus one (coin)
Makes sense?
Okay.
but, to find the minimum number of coins
for 3, 4 and 8 cents, we once again need
to find the minimum number of coins for other
values
of money, and we will be doing this
recursively.
So, the general formula for whatever
number of coins we may have for denomination
will be the minimum number of coins for
the amount of money equal to the minimum
of the following d expressions.
Where d is the number of coins in the
currency.
It is the minimum number of coins for money
minus coin one, minus coin two...
And finally minimum number of coins for
money
minus coin d.
Plus one for all these values.
And there is a simple recursive
change algorithm that
implements this approach.
So every time we need to change the amount
of coins equal to money, we have
d recursive calls.
And compute the minimum number of change
for money minus coin i.
Do you think this is a good algorithm?
This algorithm is definitely correct,
but it will take quite enormous time to solve
the problem.
Let's see how it works.
Let's start from 76 cents
and see how our algorithm works.
To compute the change for
76 cents, we need to compute
first the change for 70 cents, 71 cents,
and 75 cents
And we continue this way recursively, and
we see that to compute (the answer for) 76 cents,
we actually need to compute the optimal amount
of change for 69 cents twice.
But if we go further, we see that
we actually need to compute it more than
twice.
Now we see that we need to compute it
five (more) times.
In reality, we actually need to compute
the optimal coin combination for 69 cents
six times.
Okay, but how many times do we need to
compute optimal combination for 30 cents?
It turns out that we need to compute it
trillions of times,
which means that our algorithm is correct,
but it will (practically) never end.
Because it takes so much time.
We need to come up with a different
approach.
Instead of changing money greedily,
let's try something different.
Wouldn't it be wonderful to compute
all the values minimum number of coins for
money minus coin i.
That all values that we need to compute
minimum number of coins for the amount of
money.
If we pre-computed all those values, then
computed minimum number of
coins for a given amount of money would be
a simple
exercise, and a very fast exercise, right?
And to implement it the only thing
that we need,
instead of the time-consuming calls
lead to recursive change for
money minus coin i,
we simply look up the values
of the minimum number of coins for
money minus coin.
So how our algorithm changes?
We'll, instead of moving from larger
values to smaller values to fill
this table, we will now move from smaller
values to larger values.
For example, what is the minimum number of
coins to change
zero cents?
Of course it is zero.
What is the minimum number of coin to
change one cent?
Of course it is one.
Two?
It is two.
Three? It is three.
And four, it is four.
And now we come to changing
five coins.
And they can be changed in two different
ways.
They can be changed either by taking
minimum number
of coins to change zero, and adding one
coin.
Or minimum number of coins to change four,
and adding one coin.
Which of these numbers is smaller?
This is a simple check, and we choose to
change five coin by adding
a 5 cents coin to the existing combination.
Now, we are facing a problem
of changing 6 cents.
In this case there are three choices.
We can either use optimal change for 5 cents
or 1 cent or 0 cents.
And depending which of them is the
smallest, will decide how to change 6 cents.
So in this case It turns out that the best
strategy
is simply to add 6 cent coin to the
combination.
We continue further and further until we
arrive to changing nine coins.
Of course, it is a much faster algorithm
and
we can implement it differently without
any recursive calls.
Simply, at every stage to compute the amount
of coins (for a concrete money), we need to
look at d previously computed values
where d is the number of
denominations.
That's all.
That's the idea developed by Richard
Bellman called dynamic programming,
which is arguably the most popular
algorithmic technique today.
Amazingly, 60 years ago, when Richard
Bellman was developing
this technique, it was absolutely unclear
that this technique has any practical
applications.
In fact, Richard Bellman was working on a
project for Air Force, and
it turned out, some students sometimes ask you
where is the programming
in the dynamic programming?
It turns out there is no
programming in dynamic programming
because at that time, his
approach seemed completely impractical.
And he worked for the Air Force, so he
wanted to
hide that he was really doing mathematics
from the secretary of defense.
He was a prominent mathematician by this
time.
This is a quote from Richard Bellman.
What name could I choose?
I was interested in planning, but
planning is not a good word for various
reasons.
I decided, therefore, to use the word
programming.
And I wanted to get across the
idea that this was dynamic.
It was something not even
a congressman could object to, so I use it
as an umbrella for my activities.
Amazingly enough, the most popular
algorithmic technique today was invented
as an umbrella for a mathematical activity
while working on the Air Force project.